the first job I ever got offered out of
college was a sales job and I said I'm
not a Salesman I'm an academic and then
as soon as I opened my gym I was like oh
how do I pay rent and someone walked in
the door and I was like please give me
money I had no equipment in my gym cuz I
I couldn't afford any and I was like I
promise you I will get you amazing
results the first 29 members I signed up
in the first two weeks before the gym
opened was from pity and it was the
exact amount that I needed to pay rent
and I remember the first month of rent
that I paid I made exactly $
4,972 my rent was
$4,975 I had never made money in my life
and all of a sudden I had to come up 5
,000 in a month and then at the end of
the month I watched it go to zero and
that was the reality of the situation of
like there was no Escape I was the one
who had chose in this life but the
alternative was that I had to go back to
my father a failure look me in the eyes
and say don't worry about it I told you
this gym stuff this Fitness stuff it's
for later you've got this great degree
you go to the business school but what
would have happened after that is that
for the rest of my life he would have
had absolute authority over everything
that I did and that felt like death